you got more weed
we got all this weed right no there's
definitely that's t-shirts i can get you
a pre-roll though grab a pre-roll out of
there no hell no i'm smoking for you
that's my grabber
oh i mean this is a this is a raw paper
it's it's good for you i mean it's cool
you only smoke the grab a leaf
the thing about the leaf is like it's
such a process like you pull this
[ __ ] thing out of a bag i'll be
ripping
yeah i was in the studio the other day
with the tory lanez and every time he
needed to [ __ ] roll something new i'm
just seeing him pull this [ __ ] leaf
out i'm just like
they really stuff a whole ass leaf in a
bag and then you just find your the part
you like and then
i'm going to tell you this like
i i don't have any rolling uh
talents and i can only imagine the
grabba leaf looks like the hardest thing
to roll
no you know that's actually easy
see that's why i like to brought the man
you can roll so however amount of weeds
you got you got some lily well yeah
because it's a [ __ ] leaf yeah you
could just cut what you need what you
need did you have you always smoked
gravel leaves yeah and i was i had my
room with back wheels and i was smoking
healing backwoods i can't [ __ ] with the
backwoods hitting my runs with the
leaves and all the smokers at least nah
just grab a bucket you were never
smoking papers though
no i wouldn't never smoke papers you
know if you ever probably when i was a
young [ __ ] smoking leaves i was
treating some more goofy [ __ ] all the
bit like the big big smokers
whiz burner they only smoke papers
you [ __ ] with burner that's cause they
probably getting old and said they don't
want to [ __ ] up their body right now
it's an old guy [ __ ] is this okay
they getting old and they ain't trying
to be around this [ __ ]
losing their breath all day it's good
for you though yeah i mean i don't know
if it's good for you let's see when i
get oh don't start smoking papers when i
get older at 30. do they do the uh
spliffs in chicago where you get the
tobacco and you put it everybody smoke
backwoods everyone's on backwoods